Also Leute, der Stream kackt übelst ab. Vodafone ist mega am abscheißen. Ich habe keine Ahnung ob das funktioniert.
Warum bin ich denn so laut? WTF? Was hat Windows denn da wieder umgestellt? Alter, wartet mal. Was macht Windows denn da wieder für Dinger?
Häh? 89? 89 ist doch ok. Warum ist das auf einmal so laut? Warum ist das so laut? Ich habe doch überhaupt nichts umgestellt.
WTF? Hä? Windows? Was soll das Scheiß? Wollt ihr mich verarschen? So, jetzt besser.
Also ich weiß nicht, was da wieder mit Windows schief läuft. Aber wie dem auch sei. Ok Leute, ich gehe davon aus, dass wir nicht ordentlich gucken können.
Ich habe auf 1 MBit runtergestellt. 1 MBit läuft halbwegs. 1 MBit läuft halbwegs. Wir probieren jetzt mal aus, ob mehr auch funktioniert.
Da müssen wir mal gucken. Aber ich glaube nicht. Wie gesagt, ich hatte gerade 86-97% Verlust, was Frames angeht. Das heißt, es ist un-Streambar gewesen.
Und das geht mir mega auf den Sack. Dass Vodafone so ein unzuverlässiger Drecksladen ist, was das anbelangt. Wozu brauche ich eine hohe Maximalbandbreite, wenn es absolut unverlässlicher Dünnschiss ist?
So, ich gucke jetzt mal nebenbei, was es bei der Telekom bei mir gibt in der Nähe. So, ich versuche jetzt mal hochzustellen, weil wir brauchen, dass wir den Stream uns angucken können.
Mit 1 MBit kommen wir nicht weit. 1 MBit ist halt RIP. Wir brauchen mindestens 4 MBit. Gucken wir mal, ob das hält, ob das geht.
Ich finde es immer merkwürdig, dass es immer instant, nachdem ich Vodafone flamee, auf einmal wieder geht.
Wobei, wir wollen jetzt ja mal nicht, wie sagt man so schön, den Tag vor dem Abend, den Abend vor dem Tag, was auch immer. Wir wollen uns jetzt mal nicht mehr raufbeschwören.
Nicht hier commentators curse, dass es jetzt gleich wieder abkackt. Okay, schauen wir mal. Gut, dann gehen wir mal auf die normalen.
Dann gehen wir mal auf die normalen 4900 hoch, ob das wieder funktioniert. Ups, dass ich das noch richtig schreiben könnte.
So, jetzt scheint es halbwegs zu gehen. Ich habe jetzt den Twitch Server in Uruguay ausgewählt, mit dem scheint es jetzt zu funktionieren.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Uruguay liegt. Wo liegt Uruguay? In Südamerika.
Ja, ich weiß, der Twitch Chat ist geografisch besser als ich. So Leute, ich hole mir jetzt noch kurz was zu trinken und dann geht es los.
Dauert nur noch 10 Minuten. Ich gehe jetzt mal schnell was zu trinken holen und dann gucken wir uns noch mal kurz die Xbox Specs an.
So, aber anscheinend funktioniert es jetzt.
Ja, gucken wir dann. Schauen wir mal, wie viele Videos ich jetzt gespammt habe auf Twitch. Ich bin on und off und on und off gegangen.
Gar keine? Nee, Passbroadcast, eins, ach du Scheiße. Ach komm, geht doch. Geht doch. Drei Stück nur.
Zum Thema Homeoffice muss ich gleich was sagen. Ich hole mal schnell was zu trinken, dann bin ich gleich wieder da.
So, das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Tschüss.
So, okay, jetzt habe ich was zu trinken am Start. Jetzt können wir noch kurz bevor der Stream losgeht.
Wie gesagt, Nachtminuten geht's los. Stats lasse ich mal auf. Das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall gleich noch mal, um zu gucken, ob es ruckelt.
Wir können uns noch mal schnell die Xbox, ach du Scheiße, wie heißt das Ding jetzt? Xbox, X-Series, X1, Xbox, was auch immer.
Wir können uns mal kurz die Specs von der letzten Xbox angucken. Weil die haben mir am Montag das Ganze vorgestellt.
So, nicht so lange. Ja, nur mal, dass wir so ungefähr nachher einschätzen können, wie das Ganze sich verhält mit der PS4.
So, Lautstärke passt auch, sehr schön. Hast du das Bildschirm-Bingo vorbereitet? Nee. Ich habe es vor 15 Minuten den Stream-Versuch anzumachen und Vodafone ist wieder abgeschissen.
Ich habe mich wahnsinnig aufgeregt. Ich wollte eigentlich gerade die Kündigung schon abschicken.
Auch immer dieser gleichige, jetzt gleichige Schwätze von Vodafone auf Twitter.
Hallo, da schauen wir uns gerne an. Schicke uns dazu bitte eine DM mit Kunden an. Die können einfach zweimal hochscrollen, da haben sie meine Kunden-Daten.
Ich habe denen meine Kunden dann schon so oft geschickt.
Kacklan, Alter.
Aber es liegt ja bestimmt an der WLAN-SSID, die ich doppelt vergeben habe.
Das schauen wir uns gerne an, Pepega. Die Support-Leute können ja nichts für.
Die Support-Leute, das muss ich euch mal ausnehmen, die kriegen es immer ab, aber die können ja überhaupt nichts dafür.
Also, schauen wir mal.
Also, was ist in der aktuellen Xbox? Bevor ich jetzt mal nachgucke, was ich im Kopf habe, ist 16 GB RAM.
Eine Grafikkarte, die ungefähr auf dem Niveau von 1080 Ti ist, so übernommen geplant, ungefähr.
Ich glaube, zwölf Kerne und eine n-forme SSD.
Gucken wir mal, ob das ganze stimmt, was ich so im Kopf habe hier.
Also, was haben wir denn? Microsoft, Blablabla, enthüllt, Blablabla, AMD, ja, das wissen wir.
Also, die CPU besteht aus acht Ryzen, also Zen 2 Rechenkern.
Spielentwickler können sich entscheiden, ob sie die Kerne mit Multi-Threading verwenden wollen und dann 2,6 GHz.
Oder, ob sie Multi-Threading deaktivieren wollen und 3,8 GHz.
Okay, das finde ich eigentlich erstmal ganz spannend, je nachdem, was es für Games sind. Warum nicht?
Ja, gut, dass die CPU in der aktuellen Xbox für den Arsch ist, da sind wir uns, da sind wir uns, glaube ich, einig.
Und die CPU in der aktuellen Playstation, also ich rede von der Release-Variante der beiden Konsolen auch.
Das Interessanteste, was letzte Preis? Oh, da bin ich mal gespannt heute.
Genau, es gibt eine neue CPU, eine neue GPU von AMD, die quasi versucht, bei Nvidia ein bisschen mit Raytracing aufzuschließen.
Das habe ich im Vorfeld schon gesehen. Und das Ganze ist ungefähr auf einem Niveau von, wo steht es denn hier irgendwie?
Hier, auf ca. 12,5. Das ist ungefähr, wenn mich jetzt nicht alles täuscht, auf dem Niveau von ungefähr 1080 Ti.
Also ziemlich gut. Wo wird die PS6 vorgestellt? Auf dem Playstation-Blog oder auf dem Playstation-YouTube-Channel?
Das geht in 4 Minuten los. Wir müssen mal gucken, wenn es in 4 Minuten losgeht, ob wir das nicht am besten mit dem VLC aufmachen,
weil dann haben wir diesen ganzen nervigen YouTube-Gramm drum herum nicht. Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wenn es losgeht.
Also, was haben sie noch in der Xbox drinne? Also, wie gesagt, ungefähr eine Grafikkarte auf dem Niveau von 1080.
Den YouTube-Chat, ja, das ist das Schlimmste da dran. Wir können auch kein Fullscreen machen.
Umgefähr auf dem Niveau von 1080 Ti. Was sagen eigentlich die Stats bis jetzt? Gut. Eine hübschere Version von Minecraft
und Gears of War mit Raytracing, das ist klar. Die reiten Gears of War und Minecraft solange, bis es echt auseinanderfällt.
Das finde ich ist eine gute Sache, dass Xbox One-Spiele ohne Anpassung auf der Xbox One X laufen. Zeigst du es dir live?
Ja klar, ich warte bis es losgeht. Ich meine, wir können uns auch noch 3 Minuten das PlayStation 5 Logo angucken.
Da gucken wir uns lieber erstmal an, was Microsoft so zu bieten hat. Dass die Spiele auf der aktuellen Generation
problemlos laufen werden, da bin ich von ausgegangen. Und ehrlich gesagt hoffe ich, dass Sony da mitzieht.
Bei Microsoft war ich mir nahezu sicher, aber Sony weiß man nie. Sony baut in der Regel immer gute Hardware,
aber die Software ist ein bisschen verkackt. Und über das Dashboard von der Xbox One jetzt mal schweigen.
Das war jetzt auch sehr verkackt. Das heißt die ganze Backwards Compatibility wird wahrscheinlich da auch
nochmal richtig zum Tragen kommen. Dann gibt es 16G RAM. Das ist im Vergleich zur letzten Konsolengeneration
jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel mehr, aber wozu? Ich meine mein aktueller Desktop, der hat auch 16G RAM
voll ausgelastet. Wisst ihr warum ein RAM voll ausgelastet ist? Weil ich gerade auf dem zweiten Account
Open Street Maps für ganz Europa extrahieren lasse.
Ja 20G RAM ist, man muss es ja auch nicht total übertreiben.
Genau und es gibt jetzt eine 1TB NVMe SSD, der Clou, blablabla, sonst was. Was ich interessant finde ist,
dass die irgendwo hier geschrieben haben, dass es eine proprietäre Microsoft Schnittstelle ist.
Also man braucht custom NVMe SSDs. Mit normalen NVMe SSDs ist da nichts.
In 60 Sekunden geht es los Leute. Was hast du vor mit OSM? Wie gesagt, ich programmiere gerade mit einem
Kollegen zusammen eine Anwendung für die unter anderem Routen berechnet für Installateure.
Und wir haben es aktuell teilweise mit Google gemacht, also weil die Google Places API eigentlich was
zumindest Autocomplete und Autovervollständigungs Sachen finden besser ist als alles andere.
Aber das Routing würde ich ungern über Google machen, weil das ist einfach zu teuer.
Ich habe jetzt nur beim Testen der Anwendung, habe ich schon glaube 12 Dollar Google Guthaben ausgegeben
und nur mit einem Autocomplete Dialog zum Testen mit lokal installiertem Routing.
Also ohne Google. Also das wird zu teuer. Zumal das Routing ja nur ein Teil davon ist.
Und das eigentlich für die generierte Route nicht wirklich so im Detail brauchen wie das Google Guthaben.
Wollen wir gar nicht. Wir wollen einfach nur sagen, in welcher Reihenfolge sie wohin fahren müssen.
Gar nicht die Route selbst. Was kostet es bei Google?
Musst du einfach mal Google Places und Google Routing API gucken.
Es geht, es geht, weil man kriegt bei Google 200 Dollar im Monat Guthaben.
Also es ist gar nicht, es ist gar nicht so teuer.
Aber das kann relativ, also es ist relativ günstig bis zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt.
Aber sobald man über das über das gratis über die gratis Request und gratis Guthaben kommt, wird das ziemlich schnell ziemlich teuer.
Deswegen würde ich es lieber mal mit OpenStreetMaps gerne selbst machen.
Vielleicht machen wir das auch im Stream mal demnächst.
So, gleich geht's los Leute. Will begin shortly. Wir machen mal die Uncharted Musik aus.
Wir kriegen jetzt wahrscheinlich Uncharted 85 oder so.
Machen noch einen Amazing Count. Ach komm heute nicht.
Wir trinken jetzt, wir trinken jetzt alle mal eine Runde hier.
Excellent. Ah, yes. Oh.
Das ist die Standard YouTube. Das ist der Standard YouTube Countdown.
Das ist ja, das ist ja Loop Style, dass die den Standard YouTube Countdown verwenden.
Ich dachte, die haben einen Custom-Eisten. Gucken wir mal, ob es hier funktioniert.
VLC. Ah, yes. Excellent. Da gucken wir jetzt lieber im VLC, oder?
Leute. Oh, oh. Warte. Was ist das für eine Verzögerung im VLC?
Wollt ihr, wollt ihr, wollt ihr mich rollen oder was Leute? Was ist das für eine Verzögerung?
Da gucken wir jetzt lieber über YouTube.
Da gucken wir jetzt lieber über YouTube bevor das, also in 30 Sekunden Verzögerung würde ich mir jetzt eigentlich nicht geben.
Dann machen wir YouTube einfach auf Fullscreen, gut ist?
Richtiges PP-Galive-Stream hier.
Warum im VLC? Weil im VLC finde ich die Bildqualität einen Ticken besser als und der nervige YouTube-Chat einem nicht auf den Kicks geht.
Und die Video-Gabe, Video über, äh, die Video-Wiedergabe etwas smoother ist, wenn es, äh, bisschen, falls sie mit mehr als 30 Frames übertragen.
Okay, Leute. Auf geht's.
Konnte man sich auf YouTube irgendwie die Stats anzeigen lassen, ob ich die Bandbreite noch anzeige?
Äh, Bandbreite noch ein bisschen höher machen kann?
Playback-Speed, Autoplay, gab es bei YouTube nicht hier? Stats von Nerds, genau.
Oh, es geht los, Leute. Wo ist es? Wo sind die Embedded? Ich sehe es nicht. Egal, Fullscreen. Auf geht's, Leute.
Ups.
Könnte ich mal entscheiden, wie laut sie sein wollen?
Ich habe das Gefühl, er macht sonst ASMR-Videos.
Moment.
Bei der PS3?
Aber der PS4?
Ich kann sagen, bei der PS3 hat keiner auf die Entwickler gehört.
Leben die Leute?
Ja, er hat sich bewegt. Die Leben sind echte Leute.
Ja.
Wie er sich feiert.
Das muss gut ausprobieren.
Wir konnten eine gute Balance zwischen Performanz und Familiarität erzielen.
Wir haben die Erleichterung von PlayStation 1-Levels erzielt.
Mit PS5 war das GPU definitiv der Ort, in dem wir die größte Anstrengung fühlten,
zwischen neuen Features und einer familiaren Programming-Modelle zu erzielen.
Endlich haben wir etwas unter einem Monat geschafft, um schnell zu werden.
Das fühlt sich an, als ob wir die richtige Balance erzielen.
Ich werde später etwas mehr über unsere Philosophie erzählen,
wenn der Tag lang ist.
Das werden wir sehen, wie lange die Entwickler wirklich brauchen, bis sie sich eingearbeitet haben.
Die PS4 war bei Release nicht gut.
Der wichtigste Feature in dieser Kategorie ist das Custom-Engine für Audio.
Das ist heute's letzte Thema.
Die Anstrengung für eine größte Anstrengung für Audio, und insbesondere für 3D-Audio,
ist nicht etwas, das aus den Entwickler-Konferenzen kommt.
Es ist vielmehr der Fall, dass wir ein Traum haben, was möglich sein kann, fünf Jahre später.
Und dann haben wir ein paar Schritte gearbeitet, die wir machen können.
Hier sind die drei Prinzipien.
Die eine ist, dass die Entwickler, die die Hardware designen wollen,
die Hardware designen.
Das hätte man in der Letzten schon machen müssen.
Ganz ehrlich, dass die PS4 und die Letzte Xbox kein SSD hatten, war schon Fail.
Das war die Diskussion, die wir auch im Inneren hatten.
Es war klar, dass die Presse eines Harddrives in jeder PlayStation 4
einen positiven Impakt hatte.
Einige Dinge, die einfach unmöglich sein würden, bei Blu-Ray-Disc-Speed,
sind nun bei Blu-Ray.
Gleichzeitig, im Jahr 2015 und 2016, als wir diese Gespräche hatten,
waren die Entwickler bereits gegen die Grenzen des Harddrives.
Und viel Entwickler-Zeit wurde in der Designung von Slow-Load-Speeden verwendet.
Ich will hier nur ein Nummer fokussieren,
das betrifft, wie lange es dauert, ein Gigabyte von Daten aus einem Harddrive zu loaden.
Die Schwierigkeit ist, dass Harddrives weder besonders schnell,
noch flexibel sind.
Wenn all deine Daten in einem Block sind,
das ist, ehrlich gesagt, nicht sehr leicht,
aber wenn es 100 Megabyte pro Sekunde sind,
anhand von dem, an dem die Daten aussehen.
Lassen wir uns sagen, dass es auf der Outer-Edge ist,
das bedeutet, dass ein Gigabyte 10 Sekunden dauert.
Wenn du deine Gamepackages kompressierst,
kannst du mehr Daten auf dem Blu-Ray-Disc befinden
und effektiv deinen Harddrive-Read-Speed durch die Kompression-Ratio verbessern.
Wir unterstützen zLib-Dekompression auf PlayStation 4,
das gibt dir etwas wie 50% mehr Daten auf dem Disc
und 50% höher effektiver Read-Speed.
Leider ist es sehr wahrscheinlich,
dass deine Daten in verschiedenen Filen auf dem Harddrive
und auch aus unterschiedlichen Plätzen auf dem Harddrive sind.
Also, vieles ist nötig,
dass es 2 bis 2,5 Millisekunden pro Sekunde dauert.
Meine Rolle ist, dass ein Harddrive
nur 2,5 Mal die Zeit braucht, und nur 1,5 Mal die Zeit, die Daten zu laden.
Das alles zusammen,
ein Gigabyte ist ca. 20 Sekunden, um von einem Harddrive zu laden.
Ein Gigabyte ist nicht viel Daten.
Spiele benutzen 5 oder 6 Gigabyte RAM auf PlayStation 4,
also Boot-Zeiten und Load-Zeiten.
Guckt euch das erste Titan-Vollahmen mit 50 Gigabyte Sound an.
Als Spieler wartet man auf den Spiel, um zu booten,
auf den Spiel zu laden,
wartet man auf den Level, um zu booten,
wenn man sterben kann,
und wartet auf das, was euphemistisch fast travel heißt.
Und all das führt zu einem Traum.
Was wäre, wenn wir nicht nur einen SSD,
sondern einen blindend schnellen SSD haben,
wenn wir 5 Gigabyte pro Sekunde laden könnten?
Was würde sich ändern?
SSDs sind komplett anders als Harddrives,
die nicht so schnell sind.
Wenn du einen 5 Gigabyte-Suspt.
Die Access-Time ist auch auf einem SSD, nicht instant.
Achtung, ich hab den Chat ja noch drin.
Warte mal, ich mach den Chat.
Warum machen sie so ein Riesentammtamm um den SSD?
SSDs gibt es seit 10 Jahren.
Vielleicht keine NVMe-SSDs, aber...
SSDs?
Was?
Ich denke, fast alle von uns in der Runde haben das schon erlebt.
Vielleicht in unterschiedlicher Weise.
Sagen wir, wir machen ein Abenteuer-Spiel,
und wir haben zwei reiche Umgebungen,
in denen wir jeweils genug Texte und Modelle haben,
um die Erinnerung zu füllen.
Was du tun kannst, solange du einen langen Staircase
oder einen Elevator-Reihe hast,
oder einen windigen Korridor hast,
in dem du die alten Assets füllen kannst,
und dann 30 Sekunden oder so dauert,
um die ganze Welt in ein paar kleine Teile zu machen,
und dann ein paar Erkennungen mit Sightlines und Run-Speed,
wie wir das für Haven City gemacht haben,
als wir Jack 2 gemacht haben.
Das Spiel ist 20 Jahre alt,
aber nicht viel hat sich seitdem verändert.
Alle diese schweigen Passagen sind da für einen Grund.
Es gibt ein ganzes Subzett des Level-Designs,
das für diese Art von Arbeit geht,
aber trotzdem ist es eine gigantische Erleichterung
für ein Team, das nur ihren Spiel machen möchte.
Als ich über den Traum eines SSDs gesprochen habe,
war ein Teil der Grund,
warum das 5-Gigabyte-SSD-Target
die Erleichterung auslöst,
aber auch ein Teil der Grund,
warum das Target streamen ist.
Was ist, wenn das SSD so schnell ist,
dass es möglich ist,
die Texture zu erledigen,
für alles, was hinter dem Spieler ist,
in dieser kurzen Sekunde?
Wenn du denkst,
dass es eine halbe Sekunde dauert,
ist das 4 Gigabyte,
die du erledigen kannst.
Eine andere Strategie,
um effektiv zu erledigen,
ist, große stequentiale Schuhe an Daten zu machen.
Wir könnten z.B. alle Daten zusammengruppen
für jedes Stadtblock.
Das erlösst die meisten Seqs
und das Streamen wird schneller,
aber es gibt auch einen Nachteil,
das ist, dass frequenzielle Daten
in vielen Schuhen enthalten sind
und daher oft auf dem Hard Drive sind.
Marvel's Spider-Man nutzt diese Strategie,
und obwohl es sehr gut funktioniert,
um den Streamgeschwindigkeit zu erhöhen,
ist es auch eine gute Strategie.
Einige Objekte, wie Mailboxen oder Newsracks,
sind auf dem Hard Drive 400-mal.
Was ich hier beschreibe,
sind Dinge,
die einen kreativen Direktoren-Style erlösen.
Einerseits wird der Level-Design
ein bisschen langweilig
oder die Daten werden so oft dupliziert,
dass sie nicht mehr auf dem Blu-ray-Disk befinden.
Und du endest mit schweren Grenzen
auf dem Spieleres Rund- oder Fahrgeschwindigkeit.
Der Spieler kann nicht schneller gehen
als der Fahrgeschwindigkeit auf dem Hard Drive.
Das ist überhaupt teilig.
Die SSD ist vorbei.
Microsoft packt die SSD einfach in Azure.
Da brauchen wir alle keine SSD mehr.
Weil Cloud beste.
NVMe-Schubser.
Garantiert.
Wenn er was von 5 GB die Sekunde erzählt.
Gleich wie in der Xbox.
Oh, die sind doch noch nicht fertig mit der SSD.
Es gibt viele Plätze,
in denen die Bottlenecks zwischen der SSD
und dem Daten-Game-Code stattfinden.
Das sieht man auf PlayStation 4.
Wenn ich eine SSD mit 10x
der Geschwindigkeit eines Standard-Hard Drives benutze,
sehe ich wahrscheinlich nur
doppelte Geschwindigkeit, wenn das so ist.
Für PlayStation 5
war unser Ziel nicht nur,
dass die SSD ein hundertmal schneller wäre.
Vielmehr war es so,
dass Game-Loads und Streaming
ein hundertmal schneller wären.
Das ist jetzt einfach mal
so eine Zahl hingeklatscht.
Das hängt ganz von dem Entwickler ab,
von dem Spiel ab,
von was es für ein Spiel ist.
Ah, guck mal.
Wie die Xbox.
Genau das gleiche wie Microsoft.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch,
dass man keine normalen SSDs
reinbauen kann.
Man braucht extra
Soundy-SSDs.
Das heißt,
man braucht extra
Soundy-SSDs.
Das heißt,
man braucht extra
Soundy-SSDs.
Irgendwie sowas kommt jetzt.
Nee.
Ich meine,
ihr könnt noch eine Festplatte reinbauen.
Wenn ein Spiel 50G ist, ich meine, es ist okay.
900G aufgerundet. Es ist okay. Ich hätte mir vielleicht ein bisschen mehr gewünscht,
aber ich meine, ein SSD-Speicher ist teuer. Okay, 800. Dürfte mehr sein, aber es ist okay.
Leute, es ist okay. Der Kram ist auch Schweine teuer. Von den Leuten, die Stream gucken,
hat von Zlib wahrscheinlich ein Prozent, was gehört. Außerdem verwendet kaum noch
einer G-Zip oder Zip allgemein.
Wie viele Cores genau sind, habe ich noch nicht gecheckt.
Acht. Was nicht.
Was nicht.
The biggest coherency issue is stale data in the GPU caches.
Flushing all of the GPU caches whenever the SSD is red
is an unattractive option.
It could really hurt the GPU performance.
So we've implemented a gentler way of doing things.
A gentler way.
The coherency engines inform the GPU of the overwritten address ranges
and custom scrubbers in several dozen GPU caches
to pinpoint evictions of just those address ranges.
The best thing is, as a game developer, when you read from the SSD,
you don't need to know any of this.
You don't even need to know that your data is compressed.
You just indicate what data you'd like to read from your...
Dann ist ja gut, dass du uns das jetzt 20 Minuten erzählt hast,
wenn es noch nicht mal ein Entwickler interessieren muss.
...happens invisibly to you and at very high speed.
Back to the dream.
Thanks to all of that surrounding hardware,
our 5.5 gigabytes a second really should translate into something
like a hundred times faster I.O. than PS4
and allow the dream of no load screen and superfast streaming
to become a reality.
Having said that, expandability of our SSD is going to be quite important.
Flash is costly, and you may very well want to add storage
to whatever we put in the console.
Now, the kind of storage...
Oh, fuck, jetzt ist immer auch nicht fertig mit SSD.
...if you have an extensive PlayStation 4 library
and you'd like to take advantage of backwards compatibility to play those games
on PlayStation 5, then a large external hard drive is ideal.
You can leave your games on hard drive and play them directly there,
thus saving pricier SSD storage for your PlayStation 5 titles,
or you can copy your active PlayStation 4 titles to the SSD.
If your purpose in adding more storage is to play PlayStation 5 titles, though,
ideally you would add to your SSD storage.
We will be supporting certain M.2 SSDs.
These are internal drives that you can get on the open market
and install in a bay in the PlayStation 5.
As for which ones we support, and when, I'll get to that in a moment.
Okay, anscheinend sind es keine vendor-locked-in SSDs über Microsoft.
...so they can take full advantage of the decompression, I.O. co-processors
and all the other features I was talking about.
Here's the catch, though.
That commercial drive has to be at least as fast as ours.
Games that rely on the speed of our SSD need to work flawlessly with any M.2 drive.
When I gave the Wired interview last year, I said that the PlayStation 5 SSD
was faster than anything available on PC.
At the time, commercial M.2 drives used PCIe 3.0,
and four lanes of that cap out at 3.5 gigabytes a second.
In other words, no PCIe 3.0 drive can hit the required spec.
M.2 drives with PCIe 4.0 are now out in the market.
We're getting our in samples and seeing four or five gigabytes a second from them.
By year's end, I expect there will be drives that saturate 4.0
and support seven gigabytes a second.
Having said that, we are comparing apples and oranges, though,
because that commercial M.2 drive will have its own architecture,
its own flash controller, and so on.
For example, the NVMe specification lays out a priority scheme for requests
that the M.2 drives can use.
And that's meaning pretty nice that it only has to go through priority levels.
We could put up a drive with 25-minutes of our M.2 drive
with the M.2 drive, because our custom I.O. unit has to arbitrate the extra priorities
rather than the M.2 drive's flash controller.
And so the M.2 drive needs a little extra speed to take care of issues arising
from the different approach.
That commercial drive also needs to physically fit inside of the bay
we created in PlayStation 5 for M.2 drives.
Unlike internal hard drives, there's unfortunately no standard
for the height of an M.2 drive.
And some M.2 drives have giant heat sinks.
In fact, some of them even have their own fans.
Das machen ja mittlerweile Hersteller gerne.
Right now, we're getting M.2 drive samples and benchmarking.
Ich brauch RGB-M.2 SSD.
Okay, back to our principles.
Balancing evolution and revolution is the second element.
This was definitely a recurring theme with the GPU.
We need new GPU features and capabilities.
If we only have more performance, it's not really a new generation of console.
Of course, many of these capabilities result in more performance.
That's part of why a PlayStation 5 teraflop is more powerful than a PlayStation 4 teraflop.
But we aren't just looking for the performance. We also need the ability
to do something with the GPU that could not have been done before.
And we need higher performance per watt.
Every time we double the performance of some GPU component,
we don't want to find out we've doubled the power consumed and the heat produced.
But at the same time, we have to make sure the GPU can run PS4 games.
And we have to ensure that the architecture is easy for the developers.
Now, backwards compatibility was handled masterfully by AMD.
They treated it as a key need throughout the design process.
As our solution to adding new features without blinding developers,
we made sure that if there were new significant features,
it would be optional to use them.
The GPU supports ray tracing, but you don't have to use ray tracing for your game.
The GPU supports conditioners, but you can release your first game on PlayStation 5
without making any changes.
It would be really bitter if PS4 games didn't run on PS5 right away.
I'd like to make a clear two-point, but it would be quite confusing.
First, we have a custom game to replace our RDNA2 technology.
What does that mean?
AMD is continuously improving and revising their tech.
For RDNA2, their goals were, roughly speaking,
to reduce power consumption by re-architecting the GPU
to put data close to where it's needed,
to optimize the GPU for performance,
and to add a new, more advanced feature set.
But that feature set is malleable,
which is to say that we have our own needs for PlayStation,
and that can factor into what the AMD roadmap becomes.
So collaboration is born.
If we bring concepts to AMD that are felt to be widely useful,
then they can be adopted into RDNA2 and used broadly,
including in PC GPUs.
If the ideas are sufficiently specific to what we're trying to accomplish,
like the GPU cache scrubbers I was talking about,
then they end up being just for us.
If you see a similar, discrete GPU available as a PC card
at roughly the same time as we release our console,
that means our collaboration with AMD succeeded
in producing technology useful in both worlds.
It doesn't mean that we as Sony simply incorporated the PC part into...
Soll ich den Typ lauter stellen?
This continuous improvement in AMD technology means it's dangerous
to rely on teraflops as an absolute indicator of performance.
And CU count should be avoided as well.
In the case of CPUs, we all understand this.
The PlayStation 4 and PlayStation 5 each have eight CPUs,
but we never think that meant the capabilities and performance are equal.
It's the same for CPUs.
For one thing, they've been getting much larger...
Also, ein Flop ist ein... Moment.
Das ist ja mehr oder weniger eine Einheit.
Das sind Clyde-Komma-Operationen pro Sekunde.
Das ist selbstverständlich das Gleiche bei beiden.
Aber es kann natürlich die Architektur untrunter effektiver sein.
Nee, wozu? Braucht ihr nicht?
Das ist die gleiche Architektur unten drunter.
Ihr müsst eigentlich fast gar nix machen.
Ja klar, das hat...
Also, ich wäre eher enttäuscht gewesen, sollte das nicht so sein.
Das mit PlayStation 3 und PlayStation 2 kann man überhaupt nicht vergleichen.
Die PS5 und die PS4 sind beiden stinknormale x86-Kisten.
Es gibt aber auch einige, die auf Titel-bei-Titel-Basis spielen.
Die Ergebnisse sind toll.
Wir haben vorhin die 100. PlayStation 4-Titel angeschaut,
und wir erwarten, dass sie fast alle auf PlayStation 5 spielbar werden.
In Bezug auf neue Features, wie gesagt,
haben wir versucht, neue Grunde zu brechen,
aber gleichzeitig nicht, die neuen GPU-Kapazitäten zu verwenden.
Für mehr als eine Dezember haben GPUs eine Restriktion auf Game-Engines geimpft.
Die Software handelt das Vertex-Prozess, aber,
für die meisten Fälle, ist der hübsche Hardware
für die Triangeln und andere Geometrie, die die Vertice formen.
Das bedeutet, dass es nicht möglich ist,
auch einfache Optimisierungen zu machen,
wie das Abordnen des Vertex-Prozess,
wenn alle Geometrie, die es nutzt, offscreen ist.
PlayStation 5 hat eine neue Unik, die Geometrie-Engine,
die Handlung von Triangeln und anderen Primitiven
unter vollen programmatischen Kontrollen ist.
Als Game-Developer ist man frei, die Existenz zu ignorieren
und die PlayStation 5-GPU zu benutzen,
als ob sie nicht mehr kaputt gewesen wären als die PS4-GPU.
Oder man kann diese neue Intelligenz in unterschiedlichen Formen benutzen.
Einfaches Ausdruck könnten Performance-Optimisierungen sein,
wie z.B. die Ausdruck von Offscreen-Vertizes und Triangeln.
Mehr komplexes Ausdruck enthält etwas,
also Primitiven-Shaders, die den Spiel
zu synthetisieren, wie es sich verwendet.
High-IQ-Warning.
Von Grafikan-Programmieren habe ich keinen Plan.
Ich weiß gerade mal der Unterschied
zwischen einem Vertex-Shader und einem Pixel-Shader.
Oh, jetzt RTX-On, Leute.
Ah, BVH-Acceleration-Structure.
Ah, jetzt ist alles klar.
Das heißt 720p mit 20 FPS, oder was?
Provokateur, danke schön. 3 Monate, huge sub.
Ihr könntet uns ja was zeigen. Wie wäre es damit?
Wie wäre es, wenn ihr uns einfach zeigen,
wie geil das aussieht, anstatt zu sagen,
dass es geil aussieht?
Das wäre doch mal Pock, oder?
Ich meine, das ist Powerpoint.
Wir haben nicht einen, den wir nicht haben können.
Ich meine, das ist Powerpoint. Wir haben nicht einen,
noch nicht mal eine Animation gesehen.
Warte mal, Ghandi, sieben Monate, danke schön.
Jetzt wird es aber hier Big Brother Hype Trail.
Und in meinem Heimatland Baden-Württemberg
werden wir sagen, dass wir alle in einem Boot sitzen.
Nein, das hat der Oettinger gesagt.
Das ist nicht, ich wohne nicht in Baden,
ich wohne in Hessen.
Das hat unser Oberpro-Digitalkommissar gesagt.
Ich meine, es wäre cool, wenn ihr uns was zeigen würdet.
Ich finde das ganz seltsam.
Wisst ihr, was ich komisch finde?
Vorher hatten die manche Sachen ultra detailliert,
und jetzt haben sie bei Powerconsumption
so ein komisches Diagramm.
Weil wenn du wahrgenommen, du hast hier einen Racing-Game halt grafisch entsprechend der Generation mit vielen Frames pro Sekunde und hier hast du irgendwann Adventure oder sonst was.
We need to set the CPU clock substantially lower or noticeably increase the size of the power supply and fan.
So after much discussion, we decided to go with a very different direction on PlayStation 5.
We built a GPU with 36 CUs. Mind you, RDNA2 CUs are large.
Each has 62% more transistors than the CUs we were using on PlayStation 4.
So if we compare transistor counts, 36 RDNA2 CUs equates to roughly 58 PlayStation 4 CUs.
It is a fairly sizable GPU.
And we went into a very interesting strategy for PlayStation 5, which is to say we continuously run the GPU and CPU in boost mode.
We supply a generous amount of electrical power and then increase the frequency. RDNA2 ist die Grafikkartenarchitektur von AMD, wenn ich mich ganz verkehrt wiege.
And RDNA2 is essentially constant power and let the frequency vary based on the workload.
We then tackled the engineering challenge of a cost-effective and high-performance cooling solution designed for that specific power level.
In some ways, it becomes a simpler problem because there are no more unknowns.
There's no need to get more power to some people who work in the game in my area.
As for the details of the cooling solution, we're stating them for intended.
I think we might have to wait a few more days. So first, can we run the GPU and CPU with this solution?
The simplest approach would be to look at the actual temperature of the Silicon Dye and log in to your PC.
But that won't work. It fails to create an assistant PlayStation 5 experience.
It wouldn't do to run a console slower simply because it was in a hot room.
So rather than look at the actual temperature of the Silicon Dye,
we should look at the activities that the GPU and CPU are performing and set the frequencies on that basis,
which makes everything deterministic and repeatable.
While we're at it, we also use AMD's SmartShift technology
and send the unlimited power from the CPU to the GPU so it can squeeze out a few more pixels.
The benefits of this strategy are quite large.
Running a GPU at 2 GHz was looking like an unreachable target with the old fixed frequency strategy.
With this new paradigm, we're able to run way over that.
In fact, we have to cap the GPU frequency at 2.23 GHz so that we can...
Leute, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe keinen Schimmer, wovon er spricht.
Runnig CPUs at 2.23 GHz ist 10.3 Teraflops. Und wir erwarten, dass die GPU die meisten Zeit an oder nahe an dieser Frequenz und Leistung spendet.
Similärlich, zu einem CPU mit 3 GHz war ein Schmerz mit der alten Strategie.
Aber jetzt können wir es so hoch wie 3.3 GHz.
Und der Anteil der Leute, die sich zumindest ein bisschen mit Hardwaren programmieren und Geschichten auskennen,
haben wir relativ viele im Chat.
Also wir sind jetzt verhältnismäßig ein Chat mit relativ geringem Loop-Anteil, aber ich habe echt keinen Plan.
Wollte er uns jetzt erklären, dass die den Takt der CPU anpassen, je nachdem wie ausgelastet das Ganze ist oder wie oder was?
The final of our three principles was about finding new dreams. It's important for us on the hardware team to find new ways to expand or deepen gaming.
And that's what led us to a focus on 3D audio.
As players we experience the game through the visuals, through audio and through the feedback we receive from the controller, such as rumble or haptics.
Pass auf, jetzt kommt gleich läuft meine Java.
So, it's been tough going making forward progress on audio with PlayStation 4, particularly when PlayStation 3 was such a beast when it came to audio.
The SPUs in Cell were almost a perfect device for audio rendering.
Simple pipelined algorithms could really take advantage of asynchronous DMA and frequently reached 100% utilization of the floating point unit.
There's unfortunately nothing comparable on PlayStation 4.
Probably the most dramatic progress in the PlayStation 4 generation has been with virtual reality.
The PSVR hardware has its own audio unit. It supports about 50 pretty decent 3D sounds.
And it's provided a hint as to where we could go with audio, as well as some valuable experience.
Not to oversimplify, but here were our goals for audio on PlayStation 5.
The first goal was great audio for everyone, not just VR users or soundbar owners or headphone users.
That meant audio had to be part of the console. It couldn't be a peripheral.
The second goal was to support hundreds of sound sources.
We didn't want developers to have to pick and choose what sounds would get through the effects and which wouldn't.
We wanted every sound in the game to have dimensionality.
And finally, we wanted to really take on the challenges of presence and locality.
Now, I will say presence. We know the feeling that you're actually there. You've entered the matrix.
It's not, of course, something we thought we could perfectly achieve, but the idea was that if we stopped using just a rain sound
and instead used lots of 3D audio sources for raindrops hitting the ground at all sorts of locations around it,
then it's no longer raytracing, it's raindropping.
Thank you, user 32.
Raytracing.
Dead Space.
Back in the day, if you played the game using the TV speakers, you could tell that there was one last enemy ground.
And now, it was difficult to tell where that enemy was.
With headphones, you could tell that the enemy was somewhere on the right, which lets you deduce if you couldn't see it,
that it must be somewhere behind and to your right.
But with 3D audio with good locality, the idea is you know the enemy is precisely there.
And you turn and you take back.
So, how do we know where a sound is coming from in the first place?
Well, all those bumps and folds in the ear have a meaning, evolutionarily speaking.
Based on what direction the sound is coming from, sound waves go around inside the ear,
there's a constructive, destructive interference, and the result is a change in volume.
The phase of the sound also shifts depending on what path the sound wave took to reach the ear canal.
The phase shifts are different for each direction and also vary depending on the frequency of the sound.
Head size and head shape also impact the sound in a similar fashion.
The way that the sound changes based on direction and frequency can be encoded in a table called the head-related transfer.
Here's why.
The vertical axis of frequency, the horizontal axis is the direction, front, back, left, right,
and the color gives the degree of attenuation of the sound at that frequency.
The HRTF is as weak as we've ever heard before.
In fact, you're looking at mine right now.
Here's how we measure an HRTF.
We've taken hundreds of people through this process.
We put a microphone in the subject's left and right ear canals,
and then sit the subject down in the middle of the room.
We then play an audio sweep from each speaker as we rotate the subject.
In the course of 10 or 20 minutes, we're able to sample the HRTF at over 1,000 locations.
Using an HRTF when rendering audio creates unparalleled quality, but it's computationally expensive.
The simplest way to use an HRTF is to process a sound source to make it appear as if it's coming from one of those 1,000 locations we sampled.
Unfortunately, the processing has to be done in frequency.
So this multiple factory of transformers is needed for every sound source for every audio source.
That's a lot of noise.
This computational complexity was the determining factor for our strategy.
It meant we had to bite the bullet and design a built custom hardware unit for 3D audio.
Collectively, we're referring to the hardware unit and the proprietary algorithms we run on it as Tempest 3D audio tech.
The meaning of 3D audio and technology should be pretty obvious here.
As for Tempest, I feel it really reflects our goals with audio.
It suggests a certain intensity of experience and also hints at your presence within it.
We're calling the hardware unit that we built the Tempest engine.
It's based on AMD's GPU technology.
We modified a compute unit in such a way as to make it very close to the SPU.
Oh fuck, we did it! Sound is coming over the graphics card, guys!
We did it! Finally!
We did it!
Also, we wanted many hundreds of sound sources, not just the 32 that Atmos supports.
And finally, we wanted to be able to throw an overwhelming amount of processing power at the problem.
And it wasn't clear what any peripheral might have inside of it.
In fact, with the Tempest engine, we've even got enough power that we can allocate some to the games.
To the extent that games want to make use of convolution reverb and other algorithms that are either computationally expensive or need high bandwidth.
But the primary purpose of the Tempest engine remains the audio.
Now, 3D audio is a major academic research help.
It's safe to say that no one in the world has all of the answers.
And to say that algorithms have to be invented, tuned or implemented to realize our vision for 3D audio is immense.
For example, use of HRTFs in games is quite complex.
Before, I talked about making a sound source appear as if it's coming from one of those thousand HRTF sample locations.
But for high quality 3D game audio, we have to handle other possibilities.
The sound source might not be at one of the thousand HRTF sample locations.
So we have to blend the HRTF data from the closest locations that we have sampled.
The sound source might be moving, which needs very special handling as that blend keeps changing.
And that can cause phase artifacts in the resulting audio.
Or the sound source might have a size to it, meaning it should feel as if it's coming from an area rather than a single point.
There's also whole categories of approaches to be handled.
3D audio can be implemented using individual processing of 3D sound sources.
But alternatively, ambisonics can be used for 3D audio.
Ambisonics speak somewhat like the spherical homologues used in computer graphics.
And finally, there's audio devices.
The player might be using headphones or TV speakers or have a higher-end surround sound setup with six or more speakers, all of which need different approaches.
That's a lot of variations.
It's nice to have the computational resources of the Tempest engine.
But it's clear that achieving our ultimate goals with 3D audio is going to be a multi-year step-by-step process.
Having said that, headphone audio implementation is largely completed this time.
It was a natural place for us to start.
With headphones, we control exactly what each ear hears and therefore the algorithmic development and implementation are more straightforward.
For TV speakers and stereo speakers, we're in the process of implementing a virtual surround sound.
The idea being that if you're sitting in a sweet spot in front of the TV, then the sound can be made to feel like it's coming from any direction, even behind you.
Virtual surround sound has a lot in common with 3D audio on headphones, but it's more complex because the left ear can hear the right speaker and vice versa.
We have a basic implementation of virtual surround sound up and running.
We're now looking at increasing the size of that sweet spot, which is to say making the area you need to be in to feel the 3D effect larger.
And we're also working to boost the sense of locality.
Headphone audio is the current gold standard for 3D audio on PlayStation 5, but we're going to see what we can do to bring virtual surround sound to a similar level.
After which, we'll start in on setups with more speakers, such as 6-channel speakers.
It's now to the point where some of the PlayStation 5 games in development are extensively using these systems.
One of the game demos allows you to toggle between conventional PlayStation 4-style stereo audio and our new 3D audio.
I listened with just an ordinary pair of over-the-ear headphones, and wow, I could feel a difference.
3D audio has that conventional...
Ich sage jetzt mal, so wie das kommen wird.
Wenn die Spiele rauskommen, wird kein Mensch in die Soundeinstellung gehen, oder irgendwas rumstellen.
So, a big advancement, but...
Können ihr euch noch...
...does my brain believe I'm really there, like I was talking about earlier...
...könnt ihr euch noch bei der Switch-Präsentation daran erinnern, wie sie gezeigt haben, mit den Eiswürfeln im Controller?
Das interessiert halt auch kein Mensch mehr.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Ding, das ist halt da und macht die Spiele...
...ein bisschen reicher an vielleicht Audio-Quellen, Sounds, sonst was.
Aber da wird sich keiner im Nachhinein großartig mit beschäftigen.
A corollary to this is that there are a few people whose HRTFs are sufficiently far from the default HRTF...
...that's the red dot here...
...that they can toggle between PS4-style and PS5-style audio and not sense much difference.
I've had a few people...
Übrigens nur mal zur Erklärung für euch, was eine HRTF ist.
Das ist eine Head-Related Transfer Function.
Which means, what HRTF you're using is key.
I'd like everyone to be able to experience what I'm experiencing...
...but obviously it's not possible to measure the HRTF of every PlayStation user.
That means HRTF selection and synthesis are going to be big topics going forward...
...as the Tempest technology matures.
At PlayStation 5 launch we'll be offering a choice of five HRTFs.
There's a simple test where you pick the one that gives you the best locality.
That's just the first step though, this is an open-ended research topic.
Maybe you'll be sending us a photo of your ear...
...and we'll choose a neural network to pick the closest HRTF in our library.
Maybe you'll be sending us a video of your ears and your head...
...and we'll make a 3D model of them and synthesize the HRTF.
Maybe you'll play an audio...
Wenn es bei euch nicht funktioniert, liegt das eben an eurem Ohr.
...subtly changing it as you play...
...and home in on the HRTF that gives you the highest score...
...meaning that it matches you the best.
Das ist eine Reise, die wir alle in den nächsten ein paar Jahren zusammen machen.
Im Endeffekt bestimmen wir, dass wir allen ermöglichen...
...das nächste Level der Realität zu erleben.
Hoffentlich konnte ich heute ein bisschen über unseren Design- und Entscheidungsprozess illustrieren...
...und warum PlayStation 5 das Featureset macht.
Jetzt kommt das lustige Teil.
Wir werden sehen, wie die Entwicklungsgemeinschaft die Vorteile des Featuresets hat.
Ich hoffe...
Habt ihr paar Demos?
Von Audio, Raytracing...
Ich hab das blöde Gefühl, das ist jetzt fertig.
...oder was anderes.
Ich denke, wir werden es bald erfahren.
Thank you for your time today.
Verstehe ich den Detailgrad...
...und verstehe ich, wie die Präsentation aufgebaut ist...
...an wen es gerichtet ist.
Okay, ja.
Leuchtet ein.
Ob jetzt...
...das die meisten Leute, die hier eingeschaltet haben...
...und vor allem auch im offiziellen Stream...
...ob es jetzt das war, was die Leute hören wollten...
...da hab ich ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Also mal zusammengefasst, weil ich jetzt, wenn ich es noch richtig im Kopf hab...
...wir kriegen eine 825 Gigabyte NVMe SSD...
...die wahnsinnig ultra krass hyper schnell ist...
...weil sie halt von Sony so gemacht ist...
...die halt ganz super super geil ist...
...wo man sich vor 25 Minuten drüber ausgelassen hat.
Ich glaube, wir kriegen 10 oder 12 CPU Kerne.
So genau hab ich das ehrlich gesagt, das hab ich nicht gecheckt.
Hat das jemand von euch kapiert, ob es jetzt 10 oder 12 Kerne waren?
Zwölf.
Chat sagt zwölf.
Na gut, wenn der Chat das sagt...
...8 Kerne?
Ja, was nun?
8 war die PS4.
Ich dachte, es könnten auch 8 sein.
Der hat am Anfang ziemlich gewechselt zwischen PS4 und PS5.
Also 8, okay.
Gut, dann sind es wahrscheinlich 8 Kerne.
Das Ganze kann irgendwie dynamisch takten...
...mit GPU und CPU.
Also sprich, so wie ich das jetzt kapiert habe...
...das war teilweise schon ein ziemlicher high IQ Talk...
...wenn du quasi ein bisschen mehr...
...wenn du ein Spiel hast, was eher CPU-lastig ist...
...dann kriegst du ein bisschen mehr Wumms auf der CPU...
...und wenn du ein Spiel hast, was eher GPU-lastig ist...
...dann kriegst du ein bisschen mehr Wumms auf der GPU.
Irgendwie so, in der Richtung.
Das synkt sich dann irgendwie passend.
Was ich mich gefragt habe die ganze Zeit...
...ist, worüber er erzählt hat, was das quasi unter der Haube...
...für eine krasse Magic abfackelt.
Sowohl beim I.O. als auch bei irgendwelchen Kompressionsgeschichten...
...oder bei Takt von CPU und Grafikkarte.
Was ich mich da aus Entwicklersicht gefragt habe, ist...
...kommt natürlich ein bisschen darauf an, wie abstrakt das Ganze gemacht ist...
...also sprich, inwieweit man da überhaupt Einfluss drauf hat...
...ob man das wirklich will als Entwickler...
...dass so viel Magic unter der Haube passiert...
...wo man wenig Einfluss drauf hat.
Ich bin zu wenig Spiele-Entwickler dafür, um das ordentlich einschätzen zu können.
Ob man das haben will, so viel Magic unten drunter, Low-Level-mäßig.
Oder ob man sich einfach darauf verlassen können will...
...das braucht immer genau so und so viele Ticks, bzw. so und so viele CPU-Cycles...
...so und so viele sonst was.
Oder es braucht so und so lang...
...ich weiß nicht, ob man das haben will.
So, dann haben wir glaube ich 16 GB RAM.
Und wir haben Raytracing und Raintracing.
Also was als GPU-Architektur gibt es...
...das Allerneueste von AMD mit Raytracing...
...und die Grafikkarte macht neuerdings auch Sound.
Specs stehen schon auf Techradar.
Was, Techradar?
Guck mal.
Play, State...
Wo?
Ja, oh nein, nicht Disney+.
Äh, wo?
Guck mal, ob wir richtig aufgepasst haben.
Okay.
Ah, hier, guck mal da.
Ein Link.
Ein Link, sehr schön.
Also was haben wir hier, 8 Kerne?
Äh, wat?
Ach so, das ist so ein komischer Vergleich.
Wartet mal, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal so.
New Image.
New Image, und dann haben wir hier HugeBigBrainWindows-Funktion.
So.
Also, das ist die Xbox, das ist die PS5.
Gut, architekturmäßig, kernemäßig, mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Standardmäßig wohl ein bisschen höher getaktet auf der...
Das macht jetzt aber echt nicht fett.
Der Unterschied, will ich mal sagen.
Ob 3,5 oder 3,8, ich mein...
Die Musik bringt Drama, ja klar.
Ich hoffe, die ist nicht zu laut.
Aber ein bisschen vielleicht.
So, ähm...
Dann haben wir die GPU von der PlayStation 5, da ist die von der Xbox...
Xbox Series X...
Äh, ein bisschen besser, okay.
Oh, was heißt bisschen? Die ist eine ganze Ecke besser.
Die ist eine ganze Ecke besser.
Äh, RAM ist mehr oder weniger...
Das Gleiche, nur dass es ein bisschen schneller angeboten ist auf der Xbox.
Ja.
SSD, haben wir eine 825G SSD.
Und was haben wir bei der Xbox?
Gut, die SSD ist wahrscheinlich ein Ticken stärker.
Also die reine Geschwindigkeit...
Ähm...
Von der SSD ist wohl ein bisschen schneller oder eine ganze Ecke schneller.
Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es das wirklich fett macht.
Das ist so eine theoretische Geschichte.
SSD-Bandbreite, beziehungsweise, bei Zugriffszeiten ist ja eh das Hauptste, das Ausschlaggebende.
Ähm, die, ob es die Bandbreite...
Beim Übertragen von der SSD jetzt so fett ausmacht, weil ich...
Am Ende wird es drauf rauslaufen...
Weniger, was wir jetzt hier auf dem Bild sehen.
Sondern nach wie vor, was für Spiele erscheinen.
Da wird es am Ende drauf rauslaufen.
Und von den Specks her sind die Dinger trotzdem relativ nah beieinander.
Also großartige Unterschiede in den Specks gibt es nicht.
Mal da ein bisschen schneller, mal da ein bisschen schneller.
Aber ansonsten...
Ansonsten gibt es dazu eigentlich bloß zu sagen...
Immer noch beste.
Nichtsdestotrotz, eine Sache kann ich jetzt an der Stelle auch noch mal sagen.
Es ist deutlich besser als die letzte Konsolengeneration.
Also ich meine jetzt nicht zur Zeit heute, sondern zum Zeitpunkt vom Release.
Die letzte Konsolengeneration war der Witz, als sie rausgekommen ist.
Deswegen haben sie auch diesen Zwischenschritt gemacht mit PlayStation Pro und Xbox.
Ich kann mir...
Ich lasse es jetzt sein, Xbox-Namen auszusprechen, weil Xbox-Namen sind mittlerweile für mich nicht mehr...
Sinnvoll im Kopf zu merken, was jetzt was ist.
Mit welcher Grafikkarte kann man das am PC vergleichen?
Ich habe mal vor einer Weile geguckt, das müsste ungefähr eine 1080 Ti sein.
Oder eine 2080, die ja ungefähr so sein dürfte wie eine 1080 Ti.
So im Dreh wie eine 1080 Ti.
Also ziemlich gut.
Und es ist im Vergleich zur letzten Konsolengeneration...
...ehm...
auch bis sie dahinter gekommen sind, aber gerade die 360 zu Release war der Wahnsinn.
Das sieht man auch daran, wie gut in Anführungsstrichen heute immer noch Xbox 360 Spiele aussehen.
So und die letzte Konsolengeneration war halt ziemlich schwach, was da drinnen war zu Release.
Und jetzt ist mal wieder ein bisschen ordentliche Power drinne.
Also das was wir hier haben ist bestimmt besser als was der normale 0815 User so in seinem
PC drinne stecken hat.
Ich würde das mal ansiedeln so über mittelklasse bis obere mittelklasse oder mittelklasse
bis obere mittelklasse bei einem PC.
Also ich meine das ist kein high end PC und das ist auch eher obere mittelklasse.
Das ist jetzt kein wahnsinns, was hatten sie da letztens auf YouTube, was haben wir uns
das Video angeguckt da mit irgendwie SLE 2080 CI BAR, sonst was von MIFCOM da, dieses Ding.
Das ist jetzt kein ultra high end, sonst was PC für 10.000 Euro, aber es ist ordentlich.
Es ist nicht so ein mickriges Ding wie die letzte Konsolengeneration.
Ich würde sagen das ist so ein obere mittelklasse PC, obere mittelklasse PC ist für mich so
was, mittelklasse PC sind so keine Ahnung, 5-600 Euro und das würde ich mal sagen ist
so im Bereich, was ist denn das, so ein aktueller Ryzen 3700 oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich bin ja bei Desktop Hardware immer nicht so, nicht so auf dem aktuellen Stand außer
wenn ich mein PC kaufen will und dann im Verkleben mit einer 1080, das dürfte ungefähr, das dürfte
ein bisschen langsamer sein wie mein PC den ich allerdings schon vor 3 Jahren gekauft
habe.
Mein aktueller PC ist ja der hier, der da, also mein aktueller Rechner ist ja, hat einen
8700K mit 6 Kernen, da sind die natürlich deutlich besser und eine 1080 TI drinne, 16
Gigabyte RAM und halt auch eine SSD und sonst was, also ich würde sagen das ist ungefähr
auf dem Niveau vielleicht ein Ticken schlechter wie mein aktueller Rechner und mein aktueller
Rechner kann so ziemlich alles abspielen auf hohen Qualities und auch mit viel FPS was
es so gibt.
Also Hardware mäßig ist das besser als was 90% der Leute wahrscheinlich bei sich daheim
stehen haben.
Dementsprechend bin ich mal auch gespannt was der ganze Spaß kosten wird, weiß ich
ob es einen Preis von der Xbox schon gab, haben die sich schon geäußert was das kosten wird,
die neue Xbox?
Äh, anscheinend nicht, ich finde den Namen von der neuen Xbox immer noch kacke.
Hä, warum, warum, jetzt wirklich mal ernst gemeinte Frage, warum haben sie das Ding nicht
Xbox Scarlett genannt, das war so ein schöner, griffiger Name und jetzt heißt das Ding Xbox
Series X, ok was der Kram kosten wird weiß man wohl noch nicht, aber ich kann mir vorstellen
dass beides relativ ähnlich sein wird was es kostet.
Ich weiss wenn man sich die Hardware anguckt gibt es jetzt eigentlich keinen Grund dafür
warum das eine irgendwie 200€ mehr kosten sollte als das andere oder so, das ist alles
mehr oder weniger ähnlich.
Äh, eine RTX 280 sollte ein bisschen weniger als das hier haben, eine 1080 Ti ist ein ticken
schneller als eine RTX 2080, also ja die hat ein bisschen mehr als die 2080, ungefähr
so viel wie eine 1080 Ti, das ist aber alles so eben mehr oder weniger im gleichen, gleichen
Rahmen, alles in allem kann ich sagen bin ich deutlich zufriedener mit dem was sie jetzt
gezeigt haben bzw. was jetzt in den Konsolen drin ist als bei der letzten Konsolengeneration,
bei der letzten Konsolengeneration war ich echt komplett enttäuscht von dem was reingebaut
wurde und hardwaremäßig ist das schon ordentlich, deswegen, gerade deswegen bin ich gespannt
darauf was der Spaß kosten wird.
Ich sag's euch jetzt mal, ich hab's ja schon im Stream letztens mal gesagt, ich werd mir
die aktuelle Konsolengeneration nicht zu Release kaufen, ich war so enttäuscht von der letzten,
ich hab hier immer noch den Controller liegen, Release Edition oder was steht hier drauf?
Day One Edition, Day One Edition hier, Xbox One, Day One Edition und ich hatte es vielleicht
seit, in sieben Jahren 2013, Day One Edition, ich hatte es vielleicht fünf Stunden an insgesamt
oder so, hat sich Null gelohnt.
Die ganze, die ganzen Geschichten wo sie jetzt hier teilweise ankommen mit, haben sie nicht
im Vorfeld sogar was von 8K Support oder so gefaselt, also auch, auch diese ganze Geschichte
mit 4K und 120 FPS und solchen Gedöns, nur weil ein Ausgang an der Konsole diese Formate
wiedergeben kann, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass Spiele auch, oder sag mal, dass die Mehrheit
der Spiele in dieser Auflösung mit diesen Frame Raten laufen würde, also mich würde
es wirklich wundern, sollten die meisten Spiele mit 4K at 60 FPS konstant gut laufen, das
kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht richtig vorstellen und man darf nicht vergessen,
das haben sie bei den letzten Konsolen schon erzählt und bei den letzten Konsolen waren
es am Ende 900p oder 848p oder sonst was in der Richtung, das Ding kann 4K at 60 FPS,
aber die Spiele am Ende, ich hab da so meine Zweifel, das wird wahrscheinlich so ein Kompromiss
sein, dass die einen ordentlichen Hardware Upscaler drin haben und dass die Spiele halt
intern dann vielleicht mit irgendwas, irgendwas über einer dynamischen Auflösung gerendert
werden, das ist ja immer verbreitet da, also sprich, dass die Spiele, dass die Spiele selbst
gar nicht mehr in fester Auflösung an sich laufen, sondern dass die Spiele selbst in
dynamischer Auflösung haben, dass das dann irgendwas rennt da zwischen 1080p und 4K oder
zwischen 2K und 4K oder was auch immer und das ordentlich Upscaled wird, sodass dann
halt am Ende für 4K immer rauskommen, aber das ist ja auch nichts Neues, abgescaled werden
die Dinger schon seit 4K Panels gibt, weil ich mein das Panel hat nun mal 4K und du willst
ja nicht nur den Viertel vom Bildschirm voll haben und mit den 120 FPS bin ich mir gar
nicht mal so sicher, ob das so viele benutzen werden, weil gerade jemand im Chat schreibt
Shooter eher mit 120 FPS, es wäre cool, aber und das ist der große Nachpunkt dabei, ich
behaupte mal, dass man es mit einem Controller nicht so sehr spürt, den Unterschied von
60 und 120, weil wo du den Unterschied spürst, ist eben bei schnellen Bewegungen, also ich
meine jetzt nicht schnell reagieren, sondern bei schnellen Drehungen und sowas, also wenn
jetzt irgendwie einer von links nach rechts ziehen will, so und in der Zeit wo du quasi
von links nach rechts deine Kamera bewegst im Spiel, wie viel Details du da noch wahrnimmst
und das hast du halt mit 120 FPS jetzt natürlich deutlich mehr als mit 60, allerdings ist halt
die Frage, ob du diese Drehung und dieses Movement und diese ganzen Geschichten mit
einem Controller machst, wie man dann überhaupt wahrnimmst und ob die Spiele nicht eh wieder
voll gekleistert sind mit hässlichen Motion Blur, das war nämlich auch so eine Pest bei
vielen Konsolenspielen, dass die Motion Blur, hatten teilweise Motion Blur, was man nicht
abschalten kann und wenn die mit ekligen Motion Blur anfangen, dann bringen dir die
120 FPS zu 60 FPS in der Drehung eh nicht viel, also ich gehe davon aus, dass 1080p
als 60 FPS jetzt endlich mal auf der Konsole konstant die Tagesordnung sein wird, da gehe
ich schon von aus, alles darüber würde ich mal als Bonus ansehen, als Bonus der technisch
natürlich möglich ist, aber ganz entscheidend von den Entwicklern abhängt, dem Game abhängt,
der Zeit für die Entwicklung abhängt, wie viel Content sie in das Game packen, in welcher
Art und Weise was das für ein Game ist, auf welcher Technik das ganze basiert, ob das
ein Singleplayer ist, ein Multiplayer Spiel, ein Shooter, ein Racing, ein Entrencher, ein
sonst was, das hängt von so vielen Faktoren ab, aber ich denke mal 1080p als 60 FPS sollten
wir schon konstant sehen, was ich auch erstmal okay finde, damit kann man, da warte ich jetzt
seit Jahren drauf, dass das schon mal auf den Konsolen ankommt, ich hatte die Hoffnung
eigentlich schon bei der letzten Konsolengeneration, allerdings war die Hardware so schlecht, dass
das halt nicht funktioniert hat, und selbst auf der aktuellen PS4 Pro und der Xbox One
XXX1, Xbox Pro, wie auch immer das Ding genau hieß, selbst da hast du ja durchaus nicht
konstante 60 FPS.
Wenn man sich da Analysen anguckt, du bist deutlich besser als, also viel viel besser
als bei der ursprünglichen Xbox One, aber du bist jetzt nicht bei konstanten FPS, du
hast, was weiß ich, wenn in kritischen Szenen die alte Xbox One irgendwie 45 FPS hatte,
dann hast du halt 55 mit der Xbox One Pro, aber so wirklich die konstanten 60 ohne Drops,
glaube ich, sehen wir erst bei der Generation.
Wieso war eigentlich die PS4 und die Xbox One so schlecht, das frage ich mich auch.
Nachdem die PS3 und die Xbox 360 so gut waren zur Release, glaube ich, dass beide Hersteller
sich zu sehr darauf ausgeruht haben und gedacht haben, die Leute fressen das eh schon, was
man ihnen hinschmeißt, so nach dem Motto, die alte Konsolengeneration ist jetzt so alt,
die freuen sich über alles, was Neues rauskommt, und die war ja auch, also die PS4 ist ja rein
von Verkaufszahlen und so, ist die ja ziemlich erfolgreich, das ist ja nicht so, dass der
Hersteller an sich großartig geschadet hätte, dass die hardware-mäßig so schlecht war,
die hat sich ja trotzdem gut verkauft, die Spiele auf der PS4 verkaufen sich auch, es
ist ja nicht so, dass Sony das jetzt irgendwie voll verkackt hätte oder so.
Microsoft hat halt den Fokus komplett falsch gelegt, erinnert ihr euch noch an die Xbox
One Präsentation, wo sie irgendwas mit Football gezeigt haben, Football und Fernsehprogramm-Guide
und Football-Sport-Overlays, könnt ihr euch da noch dran erinnern, wo die restliche Welt
vor dieser Präsentation gesessen hat und sich gedacht hat, das ist jetzt schon ziemlich
Kokona so, was uns da gezeigt wird.
Und im Endeffekt hat ja die Xbox, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Xbox One X noch einen TV-Eingang
hat, hat jemand eine Xbox One, eine Xbox One Pro, hat die noch einen TV-Eingang, also meine
Day One Edition hat noch einen TV-Eingang und ich habe es bis heute nicht einmal verwendet.
Da hat sich Microsoft verrannt, das war ja auch die Zeit, wo der, wie hieß er, Don Mattrick,
Dan Mattrick, Phil, nee Phil ist der aktuelle, Phil Spencer ist der aktuelle, wo er sich
dann vom Acker machen musste, wo dann der Phil Spencer an den Start gekommen ist bei
Microsoft.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, die Sony-Seite habe ich beim Release nicht so wirklich verfolgt,
aber ich glaube Sony, gerade Sony hat sich ein bisschen zu sehr darauf ausgeruht, was
sie bei der alten Generation hatten und eben auf ihren Exklusivtitel und man sieht ja,
die Errechnung ist letztendlich aufgegangen.
Ich halte den Zwischenschritt, den sie gemacht haben, mit der Xbox, mit der PS4 Pro und der
Xbox One X, für verkehrt, rein aus Konsolensicht, für, für kein, war das kein guter Schachtzug,
weil Konsolen bisher immer im Endeffekt sowohl für Entwickler als auch eben gerade für
Käufer garantiert haben, eine Konsolengeneration ist was, das kaufst du dir und dann kannst
du das für dich optimale spielen, also sprich es gibt, bei Konsolen gab es nie diese Geschichte
mit, ja aber ich habe eine bessere Playstation, du hast, das Spiel sah überall gleich schlecht
oder gleich gut aus und das war eines der großen Vorteile, die eben Konsolen gerade bei Multiplayer
Spielen auch haben und das gibt es jetzt ja nicht mehr, also ich glaube, das war keine
gute Idee, jetzt ist es ja nämlich so, bei mir hat das dazu geführt, dass ich mir und
ihr kennt mich, ich sag jetzt, ich werde mir die neue Konsolengeneration nicht kaufen,
aber wahrscheinlich kaufe ich sie mir dann trotzdem, ihr kennt mich ja, aber ja, ich
werde sie mir erstmal nicht kaufen und für mich war auch diese Geschichte mit PS4 Pro
und Xbox X Pro so ein Punkt, warum ich noch weniger auf der Konsolengeneration gespielt
habe, weil ich mir gehört habe, weißt du was, scheiß drauf, bevor ich mir jetzt noch
eine neue Konsole kaufe, dass ich den Kram in besserer Qualität spielen kann, spiele
ich es halt auf dem PC oder wenn es wirklich exklusiv Spiele sind, die ich unbedingt haben
wollte, warte ich auf den PC Release, manche sagen, komm mal nie auf den PC raus, lass
ich es halt bleiben, ja so sieht es aus Leute, Fazit von euch, wie hat euch die Sony Präsentation
gefallen, ich persönlich fand sie halt für die breite Masse zu Resident Sleeper, für
die die halt normalerweise solche Präsentationen im Internet gucken, für Leute, die technisch
interessiert sind, vielleicht auch für Spieleentwickler, die sich Gedanken darüber machen, ob sie
nicht die Plattform supporten wollen, können, wie auch immer, war die sicherlich nicht
schlecht, besser als das reine Marketing Gelaber, was sie sonst hatten und am Schluss kann ich
eigentlich nur noch mal sagen, ich bin gespannt, was der Kram kostet und ob die Stocks jetzt
hochgehen, der Typ am Anfang, den hätten sie sich sparen können, der hat eine Minute
Intro gehabt, der Ansage am Anfang, Leute, ich hoffe euch hat der Stream trotzdem gefallen,
auch wenn es jetzt vielleicht nicht die Präsentation von Sony war, die sich die meisten erhofft
haben, ich fand es technisch ganz interessant, ich denke man hätte sich jetzt nicht 25 Minuten
an der SSD aufhalten müssen, was ich cool fände und gerade bei einer Entwicklerkonferenz,
wenn er uns mal ein paar Sachen gezeigt hätte, das fände ich cool, ich meine, es ist schön
und gut, wenn man erzählt bekommt, dass man jetzt in der Grafikkarte einen simulierten
Sound hat oder dass man irgendwie spezielle Raytracing Units hat, die sonstige tolle Dinge
machen, aber man hat ja nichts gesehen, noch nicht mal einen Screenshot, nix, das war
im Endeffekt eine Powerpoint Präsentation, also ein bisschen was hätten wir schon zeigen
können, gut, also wie gesagt, ich hoffe euch hat der Stream trotzdem gefallen, wir machen
den Schluss, ich habe Hunger, ich muss was essen, 3D Sound kam, ich rede ja auch nicht
unbedingt von 3D Sound, das war jetzt vielleicht blöd, dass ich gesagt habe, sie haben sich
über Sound unterhalten, mir geht es hauptsächlich auch um irgendwelche grafischen Geschichten,
die sie gezeigt haben und gerade wenn es eine Entwicklerkonferenz ist, hätte man ohne
Probleme auch mal ein paar, nicht unbedingt Spielszenen zeigen können, sondern vielleicht
irgendwelche Benchmarks oder halt Vergleiche zu, ok, das ist unsere SSD und das ist so
eine normale SSD, die man kaufen kann, was, irgendwas, ja, ich meine, Entwickler sind
ja im Endeffekt auch Leute, die gerne mal was Handfestes sehen, dass man sich einfach,
dass das einfach auch ein bisschen besser greifbar ist, ja, gucken wir mal, also mal
gespannt, was rauskommt, wir sehen uns demnächst, bis denn, machts gut, CU.